[Music]
thank you that the intro was awesome
like I can't see up here with all these
things fired up I'm just mind blown so
hi I'm here to talk to you about CSS
what a great way to kick off a
JavaScript conference right thank you
so what a beautiful place
we are in right I was so excited to come
here and if you google Singapore you get
beautiful rainbow skies and images like
this so here's my expectation of
Singapore and then here's a video from
my room at the hotel that's ok this is
life it happens I'm so happy to be here
still as you heard my name is Yuna you
can find me at you know on Twitter
github code pen all the things so if
you're interested in this topic if you
interested in filters blend modes a web
image performance I write about those
things online at you know I am that's my
blog I also co-host a podcast called
tools day so you can check out tools day
it's bi-weekly this year where we talk
more about JavaScript things as well
so as you heard I have a brand new job I
started with like three weeks ago and
they let me come here so I was like
thank you bustle but basically I'm doing
a lot of creative product development
and I'm super stoked to be there so
blend modes because I really wanted to
give this talk because I feel like there
is an elephant in the room when I talk
about blend modes so really this talk is
like a love letter to a specific company
that is actually sponsoring the next
break this talk is called blend modes
because but really it's called edge
should implement blend modes because
so blend modes are something that people
have been talking about for a long time
now they're not even new they're not
even like the hot new thing like CSS
critter variables
they've existed for years and this has
been a ticket open on the edge user
voice website since August 2014 and it's
still on the backlog meanwhile every
other browser every single browser has
been planted blend modes three years ago
like this isn't new it's just something
that's kind of waiting to happen
I don't know why this is this is how I
feel anyway so here I'm going to talk to
you about blend modes how to use them
and we're gonna start with some notes
and caveats about blend modes then I'm
gonna get into how blend modes work I'm
going to rush through this because
there's a lot of content that I want to
share with you and then we're gonna talk
about the utility of blend modes so how
you can really get the most out of them
and here is where I'm going to talk
about simplicity how they can help with
simplicity how they can help with
uniformity consistency and performance
so we're gonna talk about all these
things throughout this talk and then
also touch on creativity we're all
showcase some cool things created with
blend modes so first some caveats and
things to note this is the current
browser support matrix full support on
most browsers Safari has partial support
so they don't support some of the blend
modes it's really important that you do
browser tests if you're implementing
these and also to implement them in a
progressively enhanced way and as you
can see ie an edge don't really house
the barn just sayin so there's two
different types of black nodes there's
mixed blend mode where you can mix
different elements together on the page
and there's also background blend mode
so background blend mode allows you to
mix elements that have multiple
backgrounds into the other backgrounds
so there are polyfills for background
blend mode that use canvas to do this
kind of mixing but I feel pretty
strongly that you shouldn't really need
to use polyfills when using blend modes
they should just be something that you
use for progressive enhancement so two
different ways to use them also I want
to say that there's
interpolation when you use variables so
if I hover over this image I'm applying
this multiply blend mode on top of this
image of Singapore but you don't see any
change you can't interpolate because
there are no keyframe values that the
CSS can apply to make those changes it's
just a switch it's binary on or off but
you can combine blend modes with any
other CSS properties including filters
and filters do interpolate so you can
sort of get this sort of blurring in
effect if you apply with filters so it's
still kind of a little bit of a hack but
this is something to note it's a little
caveat so okay let's talk about blend
modes
what are they blend modes are any way to
combine or mix pixels with each other
through a series of algorithms and those
also vary based on the blend mode there
are a lot of different blend modes out
there specifically in CSS we have a few
different blend mode groups you have the
darken group these all darken based on
the active layer on top the background
layer
there's the Lightning group there is the
contrast group there's an inversion
group and finally a component group of
blend modes we're going to talk about
some of these with our beautiful model
here I'm sorry I didn't ask Thomas I
just threw this in there forgive me the
most popular blend mode that you'll see
is multiply what multiply does is it
acts as a projector if you're looking at
a projector and you have these two
layers on top of each other you're
taking the luminosity so the dark and
light values of the active layer and
multiplying them with the layer behind
it so here we just have a hot pink layer
on top of the images so we also have
something called screen and 3m is the
exact opposite of multiply so with
screen you're taking an inverse and the
way to take inversion when you're
looking at these pixel level component
changes we are going to subtract that
value from one so you take the inverse
of the active layer times the inverse of
the background layer and then you invert
all of that so you're kind of
multiplying the light values have you
all ever seen these amazing creatures
octopus and cuttlefish are so cool I saw
this video on Twitter the other day and
like blew my mind they have
photoreceptive cells in there like
bodies in their skin that they can
expand or contract to camouflage with
the environment around them the seafloor
around them it's just mind-blowing to
watch this so I was really inspired by
this this little guy right here
it's so cute so I wanted to kind of
inject it into our talk as well we have
our little octopus and so what do we
want to use here if we want to blend
this octopus into the background behind
it then we probably want to use
something like multiply right because
that way it just completely blends also
one thing I want to note is you can open
dev tools and just get a list of blend
modes and start playing that way so if
we want to see like screen this would be
the exact opposite of what we want
because we want to make sure that light
fades behind it whenever you have white
and you multiply it it disappears but
when you have black and you screen that
that will disappear so next I want to
talk about to bun modes called darken
and lighten these are similar to
multiply and screen but they work a
little bit differently because they work
on the RGB values so in this case we
have RGB 10 250 darkened by RGB 150 100
150 now when you darken these values
what you're looking for is the darker
value between any of those channels any
of those color channels so if you
compare 10 and 150 which one's darker
like you think about it RGB 0 0 0 is
black so 10 is darker than 150 it's a
lower value on that spectrum and then if
we compare 200 and 100 you get 100 if
you compare 15 150 you get 50 so you
create these new tones these new values
out of these colors that you're blending
same thing with lighting we're looking
for the higher value to get the lighter
color and this also works slightly
differently than the blend modes of
screen and multiply so if I want to do a
mix blend mode of screen here and then I
want to apply a mix blend mode of
lighten you can see here that you see
more of the gray shades with
and you see some of that color value
fading out with the screen because of
how differently those colors are being
generated when you mix them together so
the next two are difference and
exclusion so with difference in
exclusion they're looking for similar
pixel values and with difference if
those values are the exact same shade
the exact same color then they will turn
black so we've got some like orange on
this shirt so that turns completely
black if I remove this then you can see
that it's a shirt with black on orange
on it and then with inversion what your
with exclusion sorry you're gonna have
those similar values turn to 50% great
so it's much more muted now you can also
do this with our octopus but you'll see
that every single pixel value will be
completely the opposite color of what we
want it to be if we want it to blend he
is now like bright red stands out not a
good look for our friend here not what
he's going for
but you can use these in really
interesting ways a little while ago I
created a site called Diffie defeat me
where you can just take two different
websites and get visual regression
instant and diffic so you can see visual
regressions on two different pages you
can look locally versus your production
site your staging we can compare like
the what was 2018 Jas comp Asia com
that's the seer site so we can compare
that to maybe like 2016 site if I have
internet and it's kind of like see
visual disk because this works on video
it works on iframes it works on anything
it doesn't just work on images so you
could visually see the diffs between the
two years and it's just with a single
line of code with your difference blend
mode so the last section that I want to
highlight is the component blend modes
and these are interesting because you
can really understand like how this
color system works when you look at
these blend modes so you have hue
saturation luminosity the luminosity is
the light and dark value that it kind of
looks like a cone the lightest on top
the darkest of the bottom the saturation
is what you get when you're coming from
a 50% gray and mixing that with a fully
saturated value of that hue component
and the hue is what the value is around
the color spectrum in this diagram so
here again we have the hot pink what
happens when you mix the hue value is
you get sort of like a faded pink
overlay on Thomas over here if we're
using saturation because that pink is a
lot more vibrant you're keeping all
those values from the shirt from the
skin from the books behind him and
you're just increasing the saturation if
I wanted to make this even more
saturated I can make this like yellow or
something and then you really get the
saturation but you're just getting that
that value from it luminosity is just
the light and dark value because yellow
is so light we're seeing this look
really faded and muted out and then
color is interesting because it actually
combines multiple blend modes it
combines the hue and the saturation and
just mixes the luminosity behind it so
this image can be black and white it can
be color and you would never know it
doesn't really matter what it is because
you're mixing it there so I really enjoy
using blend modes what makes me enjoy
them and even more is when you can
combine them with multiple colors on a
single plane and you can do that with
CSS gradients so here's just an example
of a linear gradient with an overlay
applied to it you can really start to
get creative here and start playing like
if you use exclusion it starts to start
looking really interesting we can use
color and then I do want to note that
when I say progressive enhancement there
are ways to do this with blend modes
right now if your browser doesn't
support blend modes it's going to look
like this and that's not a great user
experience you want to make sure that
your user is still seeing something
still seeing the image so instead of
applying blend modes on top you can then
apply the blend mode behind the image
and use what we just learned about how
these blend modes work to get the same
effect here I'm blending the luminosity
so just the dark and light values of
Thomas to the blend mode behind it so
users will still see the image they just
won't see it with this effect on top so
that brings me to uniformity when you
kind of get this all down we start
playing with it you can recreate any
type of effect just by using CSS this is
a project that I made a little while ago
called CSS Graham where we created a lot
of the Instagram filters by just using
CSS filters and blend modes so you can
get anywhere
from point A to point B by using this in
a really creative way and then applying
that throughout your entire product
because CSS Cascades there are a few
other ones out there there's CSS Co
which is the vsco cam filters and
there's also color filter which was
inspired by the Spotify effects from
2015 these duotone effects which we will
talk about a little bit later so
simplicity is another thing that blend
modes really give you and something that
blend modes really shine at doing I was
browsing the web recently and I saw this
being shared around this reverse knock
out text effect it was being shared on
Twitter so what you need to do for this
is you need to use an extra-wide SVG you
need to hide extra parts overflow:hidden
and you need to use an SVG mask this
feels like a little bit of overkill for
me you have to have JavaScript in here
you have to have your CSS you it's it's
pretty heavy-handed when all you really
need is a single blend mode in CSS so
here you get the same effect you have
your black background with white text
and you plot your multiply blend mode
and you get knockout text and if you
want to get that little arrow thing
that's just a little CSS triangle which
you create with borders they can apply
on the end so you don't need these
additional dependencies you can just do
it in CSS with a couple of lines of code
and that's why I think it's so magical
so here's a little pro tip about filters
because this also came up recently if
you have a SVG that you're applying as a
background so I have this image of an
octopus apply its background you can't
edit the color of this SVG by using fill
you can't really edit it if you want to
have multiple colors either if you want
to have this dynamic range so what you
do is you can use filters for this so
filters are pretty well supported
actually what you can do isn't it just
like the brightness I can make this like
darker if I wanted to I could adjust the
contrast I could increase that to two
and then the next thing that people will
mention is well what about the color if
you can't change it from black and white
to a color if you wanted to but you can
because we have the sepia filter so we
can apply the sepia filter and then on
top of that we can apply a hue rotation
so I can apply a hero tation to like six
degrees and now I have a green octopus
and from here I can use saturate and
saturate it too so I have like a bright
green octopus so there's a lot of things
that you can do by just getting created
with filters that you don't need to go
into code change the way that you're
creating these UIs and just use these to
apply different effects and because it
is a CSS filter they are animatable
they're interactive you can do anything
you want with hover States etc for a
user so it's just like a good thing to
know
so speaking of filters I want to quickly
talk about SVG filter effects because
this is really where you have a lot of
control when you're editing your images
and it's because with SVG filter effects
it's really the only place that you can
control the individual channels the red
channel blue tail green channel alpha
channel by applying a single filter onto
an image with CSS blend modes and
filters they're sort of shortcuts that
have derived from SVG filter effect so
you don't get all this control but this
is also among the main of simplicity so
when I'm creating SVG filter effects I
like to use the FE color matrix because
it really lets you individually select
your channel transformations and if you
kind of understand what's going on here
you can see the differences that you're
making so it looks like this basically
you have your red green blue alpha
channels and then multiplier Channel and
it defaults starts as you have one red
value on the red Channel you have one
green value on the green Channel one
blue value on blue Channel and your
alpha channel is one if you want to
create a transformation you can apply
different values on these an important
thing to note is that the scale is 255
in RGB land is 1 in this color matrix
transform land so that's kind of how it
equates if I wanted to do something like
remove all the red and blue and just
have a green colorized image it looks
like this bottom image here where you
just keep the green channels value and
you set a 0 on red and blue so it looks
like this is sort of the effect that we
get if we wanted to do that by applying
these color matrix changes we can do
that we just have to have an SVG on the
page and then we have to apply the
filter you can do that in CSS but you
don't need to have all of this
complexity applying additional SVG is
when we could do a similar thing in
CSS with blend modes without having to
create a filter transformation and
include that in the page so here we're
colorizing we're using the mixed blend
mode of color and we're just picking our
color RGB 0 255 0 so I want to note one
thing that consistency browsers are
still not consistent about how they're
applying their color transformations
so here's Chrome you can see that these
two look as they do when we compare that
to Safari I don't know if you can see it
up here but the chrome one you don't
like to get this very well I'm Chrome a
little bit darker Safari is more muted
than these two values but the blend mode
stays pretty much identical it stays the
same when we look at Firefox it doesn't
even support these sort of filter
transformations but it supports blend
modes it's a little bit more faded out
there's a little more bright on that
blend mode and then when we can go to
edge it doesn't really support any of it
but this is a reminder about why you
need to progressively enhance your blend
modes and we can change this around to
again apply that layer on top of the
color so the other way around so with
edge either way you're going to get some
image if you do it this way
so blend modes are a tiny tiny bit more
consistent when you're applying those as
your color transformations on your
images so if you want to play with
filter effects there's a really great
resource that I want to share with you
where you can actually just change the
values and see what that does to your
image this is the URL for it cast kicked
out cannabidiol SVG color - filter just
maybe take a picture really quick it's a
really cool resource that you can use to
really understand how those were working
so from here I want to talk about the
duotone effect that has become massively
popular I've seen this increasingly on
the web and it's a way to really unify
your images on your application on your
website so we wanted to do this with SVG
filters what we need to do is apply a
positive value and a negative value for
your highlight in your shadow so if you
wanted to have a red highlight and a
blue shadow those are absolute values of
one a negative one we can do that you
can do it on any individual channel so
you can do on the red channel green
Channel or blue channel so with blend
modes you can kind of get a similar sort
of effect with some colors but it's a
lot less complex you don't have to make
all the math
you can just set the colors it looks
like this what we're doing is we're
applying a darkened blend mode on the
highlight and are applying a lightened
blend mode on the shadow and we're just
layering those on top of each other so
in the middle here you see this sort of
boxed color duotone effect layer now
with the shadow whatever color you pick
if it's a lighter shadow you're gonna
get rid of more of the details because
your lightening the shadow with that
value so you can take a few disparate
images these I just found the web and
apply a blend mode and really unifies
them so it really increases the quality
of photography and it makes your site
your page or application feel more
uniform you can use this with a single
line of code
so with CSS variables
I love variables who hears you CSS
variables not enough of you they're
they're great they're true variables
that live in your route and they just
they just work so like if I wanted to
change the shadow to red and the
highlight to yellow these are truly
dynamic variables that is just changing
the style in the browser no longer the
SAS variables that you have to compose
into actual colors first these these
live in your browser so I love those if
you haven't tried them yet check them
out they're great you can use javascript
to change CSS variables and it's super
dynamic I love it um anyway let's talk
about performance so who here agrees
before it's important all of you yeah
all of you there are four talks of
performance at this conference so let's
talk about image performance that's
something that blend modes and filters
can help us out with as well you also
don't need fancy image editing programs
that's an important thing to note when
you're using blend modes filters editing
programs in the browser you can just do
it with your free program here so to
apply this transformation I just opened
up my preview app and I removed the
color now when you remove the color cast
of an image you can get a pretty big
size savings of that image so here is
the example here we're saving 62
kilobytes or 22% of the image size and
this one we're saving 21% of the image
size here we're saving 189 kilobytes so
because image is bigger it's a bigger
payload
that were taking away from the user and
this is 20 percent so on average you get
like a 17 to 23 percent image savings I
found by doing this kind of
transformation the black and white
doesn't have to be boring again there's
a ton of we can do by applying filters
and blend modes to our backlight images
to give them those effects that we're
kind of applying to colored images
anyway here's here's that same exact
example where these colors are black and
white with the exact same transformation
applied they look almost identical so
this is probably even close to what you
want meanwhile you're saving image size
for your users by not sending 20% bigger
images to them so kind of on that front
I did want to mention this it's about
filters not blend modes this something
that I recently was doing some research
on with filters they like to call the
contrast swap technique so essentially
what you're doing is you're removing the
contrast of an image on your own you can
do this in Photoshop to get a linear
transformation of that contrast and then
reapplying it in a browser with CSS
filters so here we're using contrast of
two you're doubling that contrast of
yourself manually removed in Photoshop
so this is also a JPEGs do they go this
compression algorithm but you can take
it a step further by doing it manually
yourself in the browser and getting an
effect where you're also saving around
20% of an image savings for your image
that you're sending your users so here's
an example that I just could have put
together where I was testing out these
image savings and in here I did also
apply a single filter like a single
transformation to all the images and you
can see that here so that's what the
color looks like that's the image looks
like initially and then I just apply the
filter back to it and it's a pretty
similar effect to what I would get at a
much smaller size so you can use filters
and blend modes for performance as well
if you're wondering well what about
paint doesn't that take a lot longer to
then edit your images isn't that more
work load on the browser when I profile
this at a six times CPU slow down I
found that the longest paint time
Oh point two seven microseconds so point
zero zero zero to seven seconds browsers
are pretty good this I wouldn't really
be too worried about that unless you
have like a page of like a thousand
images trying to apply this
transformation at a time so back to your
regularly scheduled blend mode
programming back to blend modes this is
me enjoying the beautiful fifteen
minutes of sunshine
I hadn't Singapore but it doesn't really
accurately reflect my trip so let's add
some rain with blend modes you can
dynamically just on the screen do this
kind of thing apply some filters apply a
blur filter screen this onto my image to
get a much more accurate representation
of my trip here it also Ran's me of
those like cinema graphs where we have
an image and one part of the image is
moving while the rest day is still this
is kind of like a layer is moving and
it's it's much more performant to see so
here's a much more peaceful example
where we can add some snow a nice
portrait so I try to recreate this as a
gif and it just is so janky you don't
get the same kind of experience and also
if you look at the image size of this
video blended on top of this image it's
big like don't get me wrong this isn't a
movie like this can be optimized but
just to show you how that compares to a
gif it's like that change you don't want
to use gifts don't use gifts people use
them use videos if you're using gifts
send them like Auto playing videos if
you have to do that
don't use gifts but you can again use
blend modes if you want to kind of
effect live near browser you don't have
to edit after effects like you don't
have to open any video editing programs
you can just play in a medium that we're
all familiar with that we all use every
day so that brings me to creativity and
this is the section in which I want to
highlight the work of some other people
that I found that I thought was really
cool on the web and this is by Jamie
Coulter who uses blend modes as well as
video to create this inkblot modal it
kind of like comes out on the screen in
a very beautiful way you can do this now
on your browser by combining these sorts
of things applying blend modes to a
video this is a great example of
visualization by Archer Kournikova and
if you remember how we learned about the
difference blend mode this visualization
is made possible
because of the difference blend mode you
have animation here and all of the
interaction between those lines as they
blend on top of each other you get that
knocked-out effect it's really
mesmerizing I really like this one and
then finally a deadly story did an
example of e-commerce with blend modes
so this I thought was great like here
you could change the color of the suit
by just clicking and changing it as a
layer on top of this image so you know
what people have to do in the past is
you get the designer that opens up this
image they have to edit every single
color themselves and then apply it and
then send the user every single color
option and again it's just being edited
in Photoshop but you get a mask and you
create it and it's not like the actual
color you'd get when you go shopping but
now you can skip that step and you can
just apply a blend mode to an image and
do it in the browser it's not sending
your user as much data from images and
it's a lot faster I want to note that
this is something that I have seen
increasingly our websites are all
starting to look the same and I wanted
to say like stop getting inspiration for
websites from other websites there's so
much more out there to get inspiration
from from nature from architecture from
art and with blend modes with these
browser capabilities we're now able to
start experimenting a lot more adding
for a lot more creativity in our work
and I want to see more of that in the
web and also I want to notice this just
because it's the norm doesn't mean it's
the best solution so like that example I
showed with the knockout text that might
be what people are using now people
think like we have to use clipping and
we have to use SVG and there's a lot of
different features there there are
solutions that we haven't even
discovered yet because maybe not all
browsers support them yet edge so
there's a lot out there that I'm really
excited to see people discover as they
start to use this more so in conclusion
you should use blend modes because of
simplicity uniformity consistency
performance creativity and finally
empathy I didn't really touch on this
during my talk too much but blend modes
are a way to have a
common ground to speak to your designers
from these are ways that the this is a
language I understand this is something
that you can really correlate and when
you improve your relationship with
designers and with other people that you
work with other teammates
that's when ideas really grow you're not
going to create these new ideas by
working in a silo and by a silo I mean a
skill set silo as well there are things
that you you don't know about because
it's not your background or somebody
else might not know about when you work
together when you have a common language
from which to speak that's when things
can really grow and blossom and create
these things that make the web a better
place that pushed the web forward so
let's make blend modes happen what you
can do is go to WP dev user voice
command upvote them and the next break
is sponsored by Microsoft so what a
better time to do it then on their time
go up vote and finally use blend modes
this is from Greg Whitworth who works on
edge he says personally I recommend
using it on production sites in a
progressively enhanced manner because
they do watch web usage so the more
people use them the more use cases that
we come up with as a community the more
we'll start seeing a more creative
beautiful web that's easier simpler more
performant for our users thank you so
much
[Applause]